du foie gras des huîtres du saumon ce
supermarché à son rayon dédié aux
produits de réveillon objectif liquider
les stocks des fêtes
et en ce 31 décembre on compte sur les
clients de dernière minute ils sont très
nombreux ils sont très nombreux qui vont
chercher une dernière bouteille de
whisky dernière bouteille de champagne
du rhum ou je ne sais quoi ou une motte
de beurre ou des huîtres encore ou voilà
effectivement c'est sympa on trouve de
tout selon un observatoire dédié les
français vont dépenser en moyenne 123
euros pour ce nouvel an on va manger de
rose vif
on va manger des crevettes et on va
manger des escargots et on va manger
deux fois bas rayon alcool on s'assure
que le plein de bouteilles fait c'est
très important c'est une des plus grosse
journée de l'année au niveau de ce rayon
l'a donc effectivement c'est important
faut être plein faut éviter d'avoir des
ruptures pour faire au moins un chiffre
d'affaires égal à celui de l'année
dernière et puis répondre à l'attenté
des clients surtout qu'ils ont ces
périodes de crète mais de fait difficile
ont besoin de faire la fête
ce sont pour les invités pour ce soir et
puis qu'on passe une bonne fête
tout est prêt
j'étais faire mes courses mais j'ai
oublié le vin de quoi bien faire la fête
pour cette nouvelle décennie avec
modération bien sûr avant de passer à la
galette des rois